Charlie in Delaware has a question for
Nick De Palma wanted to get out of here
yes Charlie hi Charles what's going on
Charlie Kelly Krauthammer hey Nick
despoiling what what was like I like
having mitch hedberg it's a neighbor
factor today oh well you heard the joke
he did bad music used to come out of
here and I used to bang on his wall this
is before I know it was Mitch I moved
into some you heard this he no joke
about me on Letterman I did not know
yeah I moved into the shitty apartment
of West Hollywood and the the day I
moved in a super antenna goes hey
there's a committee or comedians a
comedian living next to you I go what's
his name he goes I don't know something
Hedberg or something I didn't even know
Matt at the time not too many people did
I'm like huh something like a few weeks
later I hear like guitar coming out I go
this guy must be a real [ __ ] heck but
then I see him on let him in a couple
months later and I'm like holy [ __ ]
I get the one of the funniest guys on
the planet living next to me but I used
to I used to bang him he was in a band
or his wife they would have people and
play like and I'd bang on the wall and
he wrote some joke about it like you
have to come around like I was knocking
on the door and he did it on Letterman
remembers as always used to book free
but yeah yeah I looked there's a setlist
she she had a setlist on a napkin and at
the second one it said oh and I'm on it
because I [ __ ] love that guy and just
is this a bit right here knocking out
walls probably oh let's see exactly I
stood here in Los Angeles on Sierra
Bonita yep and I had a neighbor and
whenever he would knock on my wall I
knew he wanted me to turn my music down
mm-hmm and that made me angry because I
like loud music so he knocked on the
wall I'd mess with his head
I'd say go around
I cannot open the wall I don't know if
you have a doorknob on the other side I
did there's nothing good it's just flat
it's just wife it's just flat